hey what's going on is pill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday August 13 2017 what's going on
how I figured out what the problem was
at the volume last time you know in my
podcast I think I can't figure this out
how come how come the volume I got
everything all turned up I actually had
two microphones plugged in and I was on
the one that was turned all the way down
so you were hearing it speaking into a
dead mic next to a mic that was live Oh
bill you're so unprofessional hey man I
had a major breakthrough major
breakthrough in my life I don't know if
you've read about it in the New York
Times The Washington Post the [ __ ]
Des Moines would they say the Des Moines
Herald I don't know I moved in my house
[ __ ] seven years ago and one of the
housewarming gifts that I got was a food
I shoulda said process right I got a
food processor and this [ __ ] thing
never worked I plugged it in I did there
but that but there just would not
[ __ ] work so years later I bought a
smaller one for when I was on the road
when I was gonna make myself some
smoothies it's gonna make myself some
smoothies so I could get my abs you know
so I could show up at the clambake and
everybody could be like oh what happened
to Bill he's still blinding white but
good god is he chiseled is he chiseled
can't you can't tell that's one of the
sad things no matter how good a shape I
get in you won't notice because I'm so
blindly white I'm chalk white I just you
just can't see it you know what I mean
you don't put you don't where's my hash
tag what about me what about my pain
hmm having to wear sweatpants all the
way through summer just to avoid the
bully anyways his [ __ ] food processor
wasn't wouldn't work so I got the little
one and a little one worked a couple of
times then it wouldn't work then
sometimes it work and that wouldn't work
my point what the [ __ ] you think short
out what's going on with them so you
know what I [ __ ] you know so anyways
I'm on this diet right now I got a
nutritionist every [ __ ] thing is you
know you know take some almonds and
[ __ ] dice them up with I don't know
if you've ever tried to do that on a
cutting board with a knife they go
flying all over the place but if you
have a word Pro out a food processor I
was gonna call it a word process a food
processor why why it's a jiffy you know
you just put it in and it's you feel
like [ __ ] Rachael Ray you spinning
around you're like how come I'm not
hosting a cooking show oh that's right
because the last redhead was out there
so there's another black hole in this
business for judging
[Laughter]
first a guy from NYPD Blue takes off
from his [ __ ] series like after one
season to have a movie career and Jade
and all those movies which were good
they didn't do well at the box office
and then they were like that's it heads
[ __ ] redhead males in the lead we knew
it we knew it from day one even when we
were making black hat black and white
[ __ ] movies [ __ ] redheads you know
and Eric Stoltz immediately felt the
effects of that it's all it takes one
redhead to go out there and [ __ ] it up
then they just stick us on the bench for
a while I'm just [ __ ] with you guys
anyways I'm on my own journey what I do
and what I ask the universe for what I'm
going to get you have to have blinders
on yet
hey be empathetic and be aware of others
um so anyways I went to this kid's
birthday party once and it was his
Christmas themed party which seemed nuts
to me and then I showed up it was
[ __ ] awesome there the AC cranked and
they had the Christmas songs going it
was the kids birthday it was incredible
it was actually it was a great time they
had a basketball
while the little kids were out there
trying to dunk that was funny every kid
was dunking because that's all they show
that's all they show on the highlights
you know the only way you can take the
only way a jump shot makes a highlight
now is if you cross the other guy over
and he fell down and 30 people have to
run by the screen going after you did it
you know like if Larry Bird played right
now he would never make it on to Sports
Center I don't understand the running
around all that like somebody could
literally take a full water bottle flip
it upside down and if it lands on top
everybody acting like the dude just
levitated oh I'm an old man whatever I'm
slowly feeling it's slipping away and
I'm watching young people enjoy
themselves the new way that human beings
enjoy themselves and evidently I don't
approve how are the Millennial
Generation survive do you have any idea
what though so anyways I I come home
alright everything they had at the
birthday party I couldn't eat I was
being that la douche that was on a diet
these wonderful people made all this
amazing guy it was [ __ ] unbelievably
had gingerbread men in August okay
gingerbread men that could [ __ ] with
anybody's December level gingerbread men
as a ginger I wasn't even offended okay
that's how good these cookies look all
their cupcakes they have rice krispies
treats then they had this dis breaded
chicken that just it just looked bites I
just looked [ __ ] incredible right and
was also at the thing and one of the
husband was a was was a bourbon whiskey
scotch guy and he's the only guy I've
ever seen that had a bottle of monkey
and that's when I found when I was over
in France that I finished in three
nights by the way which is why old
freckles are still on the wagon okay
my [ __ ] my livers still you know
talking to me about that one never gonna
let it go you know just like you chick
you know you did that one [ __ ] thing
oh they're gonna bring it up for years
right so anyway so I come home and you
know I'm [ __ ] starving all I drank
there was waters and I had a Santa hat
on it was [ __ ] awesome
anyways so come back to the house and
now I'm trying to chop up these goddamn
[ __ ] almonds and like [ __ ] this let
me get that little food processor right
and I [ __ ] put it together and lo and
behold the [ __ ] thing works I'm like
fine great so and I take the top off
whatever and I go to put my [ __ ] it I
put the top back on and that doesn't
[ __ ] work again and I'm losing my
[ __ ] so my wife keeps coming in and out
so now I have an outlet for my anger my
poor wife right you know it's one of
these deals like I'm frustrated over
here and that just becomes like humming
time you know you do one of those and
then look what is your problem like a
[ __ ] Jesus Christ that's gonna be a
[ __ ] 40 minute conversation there
goes my evening and that's exactly what
happened well long story short I was
trying to make some almond crusted baked
chicken breast 8 ounces to be exact
saving the rest for my lunch tomorrow
with a Greek yogurt yogurt and in
[ __ ] dill dip or whatever the [ __ ] I
had you know and you know the whole I
just said [ __ ] it I'm just gonna make
this chicken plain and I'll just eat it
with the dip and that's what I did and
I've stuck to the diet right so you know
my wife read me the riot act I'm what an
[ __ ] I am and you know I couldn't
argue because she was right at that
point my stomach was full and I was able
to look back on what I had just done
pretty clearly at that point I was just
like yeah I don't think I would be
liking me right now either so I sat
there and I nodded and I agreed and then
I tried to make some points which is
always bad when you're that much
the wrong but you know it's just how I'm
wired you know as I said you know I'm
down 42 nothing I'm still gonna try to
kick a field goal okay so that took a
day and a half to apologize completely
for and I had to make her laugh a lot
and she already doesn't like me you know
we're having like a rough time right now
because I'm on this diet and I keep
making extra [ __ ] and but it's to my
next you know meal and she just she just
you know she's coming by like it's a
buffet she'd be like I'm like yeah but
there's only like this is all measured
and they wait to after you [ __ ] make
it those good guys up and then you got
to be like no you can't well you know
get all of it yeah but I may have it
tomorrow this is how this works okay
there's a launch sequence to this it
already started um so that just keeps
being a problem because she feels like
I'm not sharing and I so what I keep
doing is I keep giving her a bite of
this bland sugar-free salt free [ __ ]
that I'm eating I'm like you sure you
want some of this you know she had some
of my oatmeal and almond [ __ ]
pancakes yesterday peaches and peaches
in it the chopped peaches in it that was
the that was the Oasis you had to keep
running to as you worked your way
through all of that stuff alright but I
will tell you you know I feel [ __ ]
tremendous my energies through the
goddamn roof so anyways the next morning
I wake up to make my [ __ ] almond
goddamn [ __ ] oatmeal pancakes
and now I'm calm you know I had my hot
water with lemon sitting there by myself
you know am i no no I'm never by myself
that's right I had already brought my
daughter up and I fed her and she was
watching puppy dog pals and I had her in
the highchair she was locked in you know
she had a little sippy cup and she was
[ __ ] you know loving life so I went
out there and I was just like
I'm gonna figure out how to use these
[ __ ] work these food processors not
word processor food processor and I got
this giant bin where I keep all the
instruction manuals throughout these for
every [ __ ] thing I've ever owned
like I'm instruction manuals for my
refrigerator like what do you need to
know how to open and close the [ __ ]
door alright I don't know I wanted to be
colder temperature down arrow arrow
arrow right anyways I ended up finding
the [ __ ] instructional manual for
both of them and this [ __ ] food
processors that I got seven years ago I
realized always worked it's just with
the food processor there's only one way
that it goes together and I know this is
basics for a lot of you [ __ ] you know
people you know who don't think outside
the box the way I do who don't have
faith in your own abilities to just put
something together you have to cheat and
look at the instructions see what I'm
doing here making myself a hero anyways
yes bill we do see what you're doing
here
so I I got it out in this like there's
only one way that it can go together
where it's still gonna work because
there's no way they're gonna let you put
it together wrong or have the top off
and have that blade spinning because you
know somebody somehow [ __ ] stuck this
hand to their face in it and died right
you know or had the top off and then
realize they had some ingredient on the
top shelf and the cover right above it
and they got up above it you know and
they were squat and as they were going
to stand up you know and old Matt and
Ben hung down there right I got all
shredded so what kills me what I've
learned about food processors is all of
them will go together about three to
four different ways but only one way you
can put it together and it will work and
that's what the problem was the problem
is really that I didn't I didn't read
the manual but now it's kind of
fascinating it's sort of like this it's
like this electric current
think it's just like it will go to here
now it will go pass through the handle
and then pass through the top and now
you can [ __ ] dice your goddamn
almonds
I'll get it [ __ ] text message here
what is the problem no Jesus anyways so
I now have a word processor of my life a
food processor [ __ ] processes the food
and I gotta tell you it's been [ __ ]
awesome and I got that little one I know
how that works so now I can bring that
on the road it makes thumbs you don't
there's nothing worse than eating right
while you're eating right but there's
nothing better after and when you eat
bad it's the opposite there's nothing
better than eating like [ __ ] and there's
nothing worse than right after you know
or the next morning there's usually two
days later if you look down and it's
just like oh my god am i preggers
alright so anyways that's that's that's
my food processor story so if you like
me if you ever got a gift a food
processor gift and it never quite worked
for you and you have like massive a DD
or you're just a [ __ ] scatterbrained
[ __ ] which I sometimes think a DD is a
euphemism for just go back and look at
the manual
alright usually the handle has to face
you and then the top goes on just so
then you will you adjust your life will
be so much [ __ ] it easier so anyways the
first week was detox I already did that
and now this second week is healthy gut
so it's a bunch of Greek yogurt that you
know has probiotics in it which is great
because you know when you drink booze I
guess booze kills the good bacteria see
there's good bacteria and there's bad
bacteria in your gut the bad bacteria is
in there for well some day what you die
would you die that that's the bacteria
that then begins to feed and you as you
decompose that's actually true man and a
lot of turns into like gas and [ __ ] like
that
which is why they always find like a
headless torso floating in the bay it's
it's the [ __ ]
your gut that turns to gas and it's like
a [ __ ] water balloon and you go up
not to mention you know what I mean if
you already got some blubber on you if
that's probably another reason but I
remember reading that book the Westies
that that movie state of grace was
loosely loosely based on and they used
to do they used to you know that kills
somebody needs to call it that the
Houdini because the guy would disappear
and what they would do they always made
sure that they would they chopped them
all up but they make sure that they got
him too so then he would never come back
because if you didn't take the time to
you know get the guts out of him than
they would they'd have a floater
goddammit there you go now you know how
to murder somebody but not an emergency
but you know how to get rid of them
anyways what did I do this weekend Red
Sox keep winning you spend enough money
you can sweep the Orioles that's what we
paid for
we've won nine of our last ten we won
nine out of ten games in August we lost
one game to Blue Jays swept the Yankees
went 2 and 1 against Toronto is that
right went four against the Yankees 21
that's three that's right and then we
swept three with the Orioles now we got
the Phillies coming up who always play
as tough got two games with them
interleague excitement then we got Tampa
Bay and then we got another big test we
got the Cleveland Indians scary Terry
Francona I still think it's the best
manager in baseball he's got them
playing great with what he has and you
know we'll see how we do against them we
got two series with them and then
Houston before we play two with the
Yankees and then we're done then we go
into the playoffs God willing God
willing but evidently it's it though the
whole [ __ ] thing is over because we
swept the Yankees in the beginning of
August despite the fact that Yankees
have come back down 18 games against us
we've blown an eight we blew that
[ __ ] lead in 2012 I'm never
comfortable until you won the division
but then if the Yankees get the [ __ ]
wild-card it's like you did not dispose
of them it's just like well here we go
now it's zero zero so all that went in
really didn't meet you
because the greedy cuts what [ __ ] 20
rounds of playoffs
black ops everybody makes it everybody
makes it everybody makes it hey if you
want to hear something hilarious listen
to Paul Versys the virzi effect this
week because he watched the Giants first
preseason game and that absolute beast
that they drafted his name escapes me I
saw him playing the Rose Bowl the
running back from Penn State he said he
goes dude you got to see his first run
he said he [ __ ] it he went one way and
they had it all sealed off he ran the
other way for like 40 yards that I guess
the giant faithful were going [ __ ]
crazy you will not find a more loyal
spate of sports fan than Paul virzi and
I know it's been easy to be a giant fan
during the [ __ ] elight days but he
has been a hardcore New York Knicks fan
since I met him I can only feel so bad
for him cuz he is a giant set a Yankees
fan he's had plenty of success right in
his lifetime that he's remembered they
have won five World Series and two Super
Bowls there's pretty goddamn good right
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about hockey they
Rangers won a Stanley Cup he's not a
Mets fan they want an 86
here we go Feldman he got to work it all
out don't you then who's left oh the
Jets Jesus Christ I think just goes
downhill anyways he was all excited
about that I did not see how my Patriots
were doing um this might be Tom Brady's
last year maybe next year it's all
winding down and I'm waiting to see who
in the AFC is gonna step up I mean from
the rumblings I heard that seems like
the Jets seem like the the odds-on
favorite to be the next one to have a
run as long as Bill Belichick sticks
around and after Brady leaves at least
within the next three years we'll see
how that goes but what a run what a run
- they got another one in him I don't
know
we won five out of eight I couldn't be
[ __ ] happier speaking of not being
could not be happier did anybody watch
any motorcycle racing yesterday or these
past two weeks believe the one last two
weeks ago was in Berlin I think it was
somewhere in Germany
these last two [ __ ] races
I've been so goddamn exciting let's just
talk about yesterday's Austrian Grand
Prix Austrian I believe birthplace of
Adolf Hitler I believe okay you know
what's so [ __ ] I think it's just
because I live over here whenever I go
over there that's all I ever think all
right whenever I'm in Paris I'm like
yeah and I walk up the Shabbos alizée
I'm like Hitler drove down this [ __ ]
Street in a Mercedes Benz standing up
[ __ ] waving to the crowd like he just
won a Super Bowl you know and I think if
you just grew up over there it just
seems like olden days [ __ ] because you
know when I sit out here in Los Angeles
I don't think like a there was some
Native Americans here you know living
off the land did not steal in any water
anyways you got to watch that [ __ ] you
get if you're gonna get into racing if
you're like if you seems like they're
riding around the [ __ ] circle you
need excitement motorcycle racing is
where it's at MotoGP is the best racing
out there okay and the show the past two
weeks that Jorge Lorenzo Marc Marc
Marquez in Andre dove and race Davitt Co
so I hope that's how you say his first
name I have put on it's been it's been
fight they had me off the couch miming
rolling on the throttle I was screaming
at the [ __ ] TV the last couple of laps
they're basically doing I don't know 160
170 180 miles an hour almost bumping
into each other like they're racing on
horses which is dangerous enough and
what do you what I'm finding is is these
Ducatis have an incredible amount of
torque that the Honda can't [ __ ] with in
Jorge Lorenzo and the vit Co so both are
on the on the Ducati team Jesus Christ I
just spaced took on the Ducati team Marc
Marquez is on the Honda and Laird Lana I
heard
today there Jorge Lorenzo's is gonna go
to the Beretta Honda next year I don't
why the [ __ ] he would do that with his
skills why would you want to be on like
a slower bike but Marc Marquez I think I
don't know I think he just he just rides
perfectly so he gets him in the corners
and he just takes the perfect line
around the track beef literally the
fastest way around the track and then in
the beginning of this race cuz last
weeks right he he came in third which is
a massive failure in his world in two
videos on Jorge Lorenzo just they passed
each other like three times on the final
lap and this week Marc Marquez and Jorge
Lorenzo there was three passes on the
final lap it was [ __ ] unbelievable
and in the beginning of the race Marc
Marquez I think was just he kind of knew
the power that the Ducati had so he was
just trying to [ __ ] put as much space
between himself and the Ducatis as he
could it's so fascinating that the tire
that they're on and then Jorge was kind
of like laying back but Davitt see also
was I think what's laying back couldn't
get around Lorenzo but then you don't
know if that's a strategy like I you're
on softer tires go ahead and let you run
a little bit like you chew up your
[ __ ] tires I'm on a harder time and
then I'm gonna [ __ ] you know after
the race is like halfway over but they
do this subtle thing where they they
hang back but they still press the
person
so hopefully their tires are all [ __ ]
chewed up and they don't have as good a
grip and then they can they can run them
down in the end I barely know what I'm
talking about but I have to tell you it
is [ __ ] incredible you have to get
into it and here's another great thing
most races it's like 25 26 27 laps
there's no pit stops it's a perfect
thing for an American to get into it's
fast
it's exciting and there's no brakes okay
even though we have a bunch of timeouts
and [ __ ] it's like you suck you
fast-forwarding through the commercials
there's like no [ __ ] commercials
cannot say enough about it and for those
who actually pay attention Marc Marquez
looks like he's gonna win the
championship he's way out in front I
don't know what happened to Rossi this
week he
most had some sort of grid penalty or he
crashed I don't know what but he started
in like 14th place but that [ __ ] guy
is he's second in points but as far as
winds go Marquez has won five this year
Lorenzo's won three David Co so is one
two and Marquez has been on nine
different podiums he's like on the pony
he's been on the podium every race but -
so he's way out front his like 200
points and the next closest guys
Valentino I think he has like 130 140 so
it's pretty safe to say barring anything
major that Marquez is going to win this
again but I'll tell you the the the show
the three of them are putting on is
[ __ ] it's unbelievable and I have I
got to go to that MotoGP race there's
only one in the United States if you
want to go and there's only one Formula
One race if you want to see Lewis
Hamilton who's gonna go on to be one of
the Great's of all time it's in Austin
Texas and I highly recommend it anyways
alright let me do let me do a little
couple of [ __ ] reads here for the
week there
alright hotel tonight alright tonight is
hotel tonight is the go to app for
booking great deals at great hotels
unlike other hotel booking sites hotel -
I'm not gonna do that the whole time
doesn't have long endless lists of a
zillion hotel choices instead instead
hotel tonight it shows you only the best
deals at the best hotels they partner
with the top-rated hotels to help them
fill their unsold rooms which is how you
get such a great deal so they kind of
like every other one but they're not
gonna give you oh here's a motel four
and a half they're only gonna give you
the best ones and even though the name
is hotel - it's not just for tonight
you can book - tomorrow or beyond it's
perfect for planners as well as
procrastinators you can book spontaneous
weekend's three-day getaways staycations
road trips business trips you can book a
hotel just so you can use the pool etc
download the hotel tune to today to get
great deals at hotels you actually want
to stay it and with the promo code bar
you can get $25 off your first eligible
booking that's Hotel 2 promo code bar
policy genius dude he's [ __ ] wicked
life insurance is really important but
it's also really confusing no one to FOA
out of 10 people don't have it and maybe
you're one of those people I have it I
have it you know tell you right now I
have such I have such an incredible
amount of life insurance I bet my wife
last night when I was such a dick to her
probably thought about taking me up but
if anything were to happen it's
important that your loved ones are taken
care of that's so true cuz I know a lot
of guys that died unexpectedly and they
did not have their affairs in order and
to say that that's a little bit of a
curveball is is an understatement
besides life insurance besides life
insurance rates are at the lowest
they've been in 20 years the best time
to buy is now and the best place to buy
is policy genius.com
policy genius is the easy way to compare
life insurance online in just five
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find the best policies
for you and when you compare quotes you
save money it's that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance and placed over
twenty billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they can cover it
if you've been putting off getting life
insurance there's no reason to put it up
any longer
guys I know a lot of you don't want to
do it I didn't want to do it because you
contemplate your own death but I have to
tell you when you get life insurance
that this is like this weight off of
your chest because part of it is you
know alright I don't want to admit that
I'm gonna die someday but knowing that
if you died everybody in your family is
gonna be ok is huge ok so you don't have
to sit there like haunting the house
with a [ __ ] tear in your eye
and she watched everybody [ __ ]
sharing a bowl of great netflix all
right if you've been putting off life
insurance there's no reason to put it
off any longer longer go to policy
genius.com for all you dummies out there
genius has spelled GE and i us i was
really talking to myself get quotes and
apply in minutes it's that easy
you could go do it right now and you
should because rates are their lowest in
20 years policy genius pol i see why GE
and i us.com
the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance all right is there a promo
code so they know that I sent you there
alright VPN alright this is last one all
right Victor Papa November simply safe
home security is the home security that
finally gets it right
simply safe started ten years ago with a
mission to fix the industry they cut out
contracts middlemen and pushy sales guys
they made it easy to set up your system
with no hard wiring or tools with simply
safe
you get professionally monitored 24/7
protection for just fifteen dollars a
month that's your home home protected by
policy dispatch and fire dispatch
dispatch I'm sorry everyone loves this
system everyone loves it okay they love
how it works and how easy it is to use
today simply say protection over two
million people
they've won Editors Choice Awards from C
and et PC Magazine and wire go to simply
safe BER calm today to order your simply
safe system you get a 60 day risk-free
trial trial that simply saved BER calm
simply safe
bur calm you know what I forgot to tape
yesterday on me-tv
on Sunday nights you know what they got
they got oh they got Columbo how long I
mean we just ask you one more question I
might be
I'm having some you slump you shot
confused me just a little bit here I
just got a uh I love that I love the
walk away and then he would come back
okay I see I see you didn't do it then
but uh
oh I'm showing a body and I'm sure yeah
you can get back to working out and then
he goes to walk away
oh yeah just one more question and
that's the question that gets the guy's
[ __ ] brow sweating unbelievable
[ __ ] show one of my favorite memories
of my adult life was I was in Rome Italy
as opposed to Rome North Carolina bill I
was in Rome I was getting ready to do a
run of dates so I had to get acclimated
to the time so I went over there five
days early with my lovely wife and my
mother-in-law and we were all jet-lagged
in at 3:00 in the morning we were
watching [ __ ] Columbo somehow it was
in English I believe I had to open
because we were watching it and uh we
just it was a [ __ ] greatest night
ever just one of those [ __ ] nights
you didn't you're on vacation didn't
have anything to do and then Colombo
comes on at 3:00 in the morning and we
just had the best time ever watching oh
it's such a great show was there
anything else that I wanted to talk
about before I get into your questions
for the week a little pressed for time
here
oh so any Oh God you know I've been
going to the gym now everything's going
great I'm turning my my ass cheeks I
don't know if I mentioned to this I
didn't mention this to you but people
who might have missed last week's
podcast I figured out the reason why I
kept having this sciatic nerve problem
was because of 20 years of being on the
road sitting in writers rooms just
sitting down in general and not doing
legs the way I should have my [ __ ]
glutes turned into [ __ ] two pieces of
veal cutlet and I'm just sitting on skin
and bones back there so after a while
the the sciatic nerve gets in pinch so
anyways I I've been doing my legs
religiously and I don't know I'm
starting to have a little bit of cube
steak back there still a poor cut of
meat but I am I
dedicated to doing this if somebody told
me a long time ago that one of the great
things to do is to to constantly to
never stop doing squats because you know
as you become like an older person and
everything you want to be able to get up
and out of bed get up and out of a chair
and that type of stuff and and then also
your quads are the biggest muscle in
your body so it's gonna burn the most
fat and all of this [ __ ] so anyways I'm
not gonna lie to you guys I've been I've
been really talking to some people for
the first time in my life and I've
realized how many exercises I did it the
gym with terrible form so now I have my
form down pat like I have my shoulders
down and back and speaking of my back
like I've really been working all my
back muscles and everything because you
know being a child of the 80s it was all
do what can you bench
what can you bench right and it was all
benching and currently he do tries or
whatever but you wouldn't do it and you
would you would you do that [ __ ] you
know like I was talking about would be
like you know if you--you'll picking up
somebody's luggage you know straight up
to do your trapeze he's there but you
wouldn't do the Miller your back your
lower back or anything your shoulders
would get pulled forward and up and then
you'd be benching like that and then
eventually you blow out your [ __ ]
rotator cuff so I now know not to do
that I'm still not benching I'd bench
now I do like eventually I'm just gonna
do like dumbbells because it allows your
shoulders to move independently you know
so you're not married to one shoulder or
the other you know it's almost like you
know that different all that
differential works in your car right it
allows both wheels in the back to turn
independently so one doesn't get [ __ ]
around the turn faster than the other
for all you mechanics out there so I was
watching this guy at the gym today and
like the lat pulldown is the big [ __ ]
exercise that I need to do if I'm
eventually gonna get back to do one be
able to handle my body weight to do a
pull-up again so I can win my bet of
being able to do 10 of those when I'm 70
I have less than 20 years before I'm 70
if you could [ __ ] believe that's
fast life goes by started this podcast
so it's only $30 so this guy comes in
he's probably my age but in my vein
veinous I probably thinks he's like five
years older than me but I do that a lot
why I think people at 10 years old I
mean they're like three years younger
than me and it's obviously not because
the way I look it's my [ __ ] vanity so
this guy I think he's in a hurry or
whatever but he was doing these lat
[ __ ] pull downs and it was like
rather than sitting up you know sitting
up straight shoulders down and back and
then not letting your shoulders coming
up standing up grabbing the bar and then
coming down and I do you know explode
down one two and then one two three four
going up right with weight that you can
handle keeping your shoulders down and
back this [ __ ] guy was doing almost
the whole stack and what how he would
get it down was he brought it down he
would like lean back and then he would
he would use the momentum of leaning
back and then pull it down and I took
video really you know I would never show
this guy on the internet but just to
show my trainer and I was just like just
out of curiosity what muscles is this
person actually working instead of their
lats because it's the lat pulldown and
the person looked at it and said he's
working his triceps his groin and he's
on his way to having a herniated disc
and I got to tell you the amount of
[ __ ] people that I've seen in there
now I'm not trying to be you know I know
a couple I know my form now so I'm
trying to be like this snob at the gym
I'm just letting you guys know haven't
worked through this [ __ ] injury for
the last two years because I was that
guy I was never quite that bad but my
shoulders were up and all that and I had
this big [ __ ] problem that ended up
being a blessing because I found out how
[ __ ] up my body was and I needed to
get it all untwisted and all you know
[ __ ] yoked in all these different
places and now I'm trying to build it
back up again but I was always one of
those people like why am I gonna get a
personal trainer like I would always
just look at somebody doing an exercise
and be like oh what's that for okay I'll
try those and
i its [ __ ] pointless unless you get
the form down so you really should get a
trainer and then I imagine trainers are
just like comedians where you know you
have your top 10% the David tells the
Dave Chappelle's those level and then
you got a bunch of [ __ ] dick joke
hacks out there that you got to make
sure that you have like the right
[ __ ] person and I guess the red flag
would be if they just said hey do this
exercise and they didn't work too much
on your form make sure you get somebody
that that teaches you the form and all
of that and so you don't hurt yourself
in to end up in a situation that I'm in
and that poor bastard at the gym I
wanted to say something to him but he
had like this [ __ ] crazy type-a I'm
in a [ __ ] rush vibe I think I have
I'm not gonna sit so much like telling
somebody that they're working out wrong
is almost like going up to somebody you
don't know and giving them advice on how
to raise their kid I feel like this what
do you guys think it's just something
you don't do I think if you were like a
personal trainer you almost have to come
in like an apology
amen not trying to get in your kitchen
here buddy but uh you're gonna you're
gonna get a herniated disk doing that
but then you he's gonna have to like go
into his ego and be a take half of what
you're lifting and then do it the right
way and I just don't think he's you know
you know what back doctors need business
- why the [ __ ] am I gonna get involved
you know what am I good time I go there
and start mansplaining and then all of a
sudden the lesbians at the gym and the
feminists start yelling she shouldn't
say lesbian I should say feminists right
I'm sure there's some open-minded
lesbians out there that wouldn't mind a
little lat pulldown [ __ ] uh
explanation all right if you were
confused by that don't worry I was -
okay let's get into the questions for
the week here
fresh box okay wait let me see here okay
bill Grady emails for the week fresh box
23 got a lot of responses your request
for advice for the 23 year old virgin in
London with strict parents
I only concluded responses from chicks
cuz that's who you asked to get emails
in from but it should be noted about 50
guys wrote in with their advice
responses from around the world with
different advice yeah I figured you know
women would know better so anyways it's
this woman she's 23 she's working on a
goddamn doctorate or something crazy
like that and she wants to know she's a
virgin she wants to know how to get out
there and meet a nice fella instead of
uh some guy on tinder I believe is the
bad dating site that's a reference I
hear younger comics using all right
fresh bouquet see some women helping out
fresh box 23 okay cuz cuz vaginas fresh
as in any dirty dicks in there and she's
23 years old that's right fresh box 23
was in the subject okay alright clam
podcast listener alright hey there
Bilbo Baggins I'm a fellow clam podcast
listener of responding to the 23 year
old lady who wrote on your Monday
morning podcast don't go on them don't
go on them dating apps most of them just
want to bang or they are closeted gay
men or they are serial killers who still
live with their moms I also did not date
until my mid-20s for the same reason and
I found that the most effective way to
meet guys was to get a bunch of single
girlfriends and go speed dating you get
to meet these men in the flesh and see
them sweating in their shirts awkwardly
palming their sweaty drinks where do you
go speed dating it's funny and endearing
and you'll have a better chance getting
matched to a human being the fact that
they were nervous I would think that
there there's something about them that
they're a better guy you know I can't
say a better guy but then you don't want
to be all nervous when they're going out
in the job world
it's a difficult difficult thing trying
to pick the right person anyways other
options are to join a church group that
does charity work or me to pheasant good
there you meet somebody or as a fellow
studious working professional at school
but don't bang anyone at work that's how
I'm now that's how I met my now
soon-to-be ex-husband oh my god so you
just gave all of this great advice and
then you have a failed relationship at
the end what is she supposed to do I
think there was some good things there
join a church group that does charity
work maybe not through the church if
you're not into that [ __ ] do some
charity work but then just make sure you
give your vet because that's also where
I would think a cycle might go to try to
get some you know you know some
open-minded / a little naive when it
comes to street smarts always have your
guard up oh did I mention I saw that
movie 8th grade did I tell you that and
I know I didn't I went to go see it I
didn't even know bo burnham directed it
I just heard it was good and goddamn it
I wanted to see a movie and I went to go
see it and it's it's [ __ ] great it's
great there's one scene in there that is
excruciating to watch but I think it's
important that you know like preteen
teen girls see it because there's it's
really a I don't know it's [ __ ]
brutal it's a lot of creeps out there
alright but it doesn't get you know it
gets creepy enough but not to the point
we like I wish I never saw this [ __ ]
movie but it's you know the way it was
handled I thought was was was perfect
and it's great to see a [ __ ] comedian
out there directing a movie that good
huh everybody thinks all we could do is
jump around talking about our dicks look
at that look at Bo Burnham crushing it
so go check that out support a fellow
comedian and supports cinema live cinema
all right fresh box 23 hey Billy Bob L
dick great one I freaking love your
podcast you're truly the inner monologue
in my head for almost
every scenario in my life I find myself
in I'm a 29 year old from Dortch - I
have dude
Dorchester Mass and I'm a biology
student in a committed relationship
my advice to this broad from England
looking for love dating apps or what I
would describe as a last resort and I
believe that's something that I
suggested to her maybe I'm just old
school but the reality is most people
aren't dating apps are most people in
real life these days what you see on
bumble is what you see in real life
there's not really one app that's better
than the other they all house most of
the douchebaggery in the world so what's
the difference me people platonically is
what I would suggest
who wants a baby daddy from tinder all
right well how does she do this but hey
Who am I to judge
get some girlfriends then they introduce
you to single friends at a [ __ ]
barbecue or some [ __ ] like that
I dunno some girlfriends who have met
their husbands off dating sites but hey
come to think of it their husbands
seriously suck seriously suck just so
many dicks on so many levels
alright so I think dating apps is out
that's what I've learned so far keep on
keepin on I can't wait to see you at the
garden oh wait wait that's it so what
was your advice okay basically stay away
from the dating apps it seems like you
get with a group of girlfriends you go
out in a herd as the guys are in the
tall grass peaking up waiting to find a
weak one and I guess somehow you I don't
know anyways right
let me just read the rest of this keep
on keepin on it can't wait to see it the
guide in October bill you redheaded
stepchild and hey England brought its
it'll get easier just stick your tits
out there and it
it's like flies to honey you'll quickly
realize how easy it is all right there's
a lot of advice in a lot of different
directions in there but you know she's
studying biology and she's from
Dorchester so she's getting a lot of
mixed signals here all right fresh
Brock's 23 from a lady
dear Billy big tits I just finished
listening to your podcast of August 6th
and I have a few suggestions for the
girl who's late to the dating game I'm
only 21 but I'm certainly not fresh out
of the box that I know you think's
number one use bumble not tinder okay
now she's saying she's saying a dating
app on bumble the girls have to message
first so you can do some flirting
oh so you can do all that smart flirty
you could do some filtering out of dudes
who seem creepy without feeling pressure
to respond to a message tinder is good
if you want to get laid if you're trying
to weed out the guys who just want to
get their dicks wet tell them you're
saving yourself until marriage you can
always change your mind later quote oh
so you just tell them you saving
yourself till marriage and that just
makes a bunch of get most of the guys
will just who are just looking to get
laid I guess we'll leave you alone
anyways number two my friends love to
pick me out I'm sure if you ask yours
they would - three like bill said find
in activity lots of cities have sports
leagues that could that could be a good
place to spot to start thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself
I really think out of all the advice
that I just read there I would say stay
away from all dating apps and I you need
to get a hobby
you need to carve out some time some
social time and like you know some sort
of sport charity work a cooking class
just get yourself out there where it's
like those are really good I feel like
there's a lot of decent people in those
things sports you know you could find
the controlling type a dick but you know
that guy else is going to crush it a lot
of times in the real world so it depends
on if you want an in-ground pool or not
I don't know what you're looking for
but there you go there's some advice for
you good luck and don't settle
alright don't settle but guys being a
dick [ __ ] him there's this you know
there's gonna be a good guy out there
for you no you don't ever have to
[ __ ] sell send it back this foods too
cold alright black guys perspective on
stand your ground right dear bill hope
the lovely Nia and the talented toddler
are doing well all right
first off there's a lot of white guys
saying they're black guys on the
internet so we'll see how this goes or
there's a lot of Republicans saying
they're Democrats and vice versa you
know I'm a Republican and I gotta say no
I hate Donald Trump and I'm a Republican
they always do that [ __ ] so who knows
that this guy's black or not but anyways
here we go I wanted to share my opinion
on the growing frustrations with
situations like this and how they are
handled viewed and discuss know resists
respect to you or your platform I
respect where you're coming from on this
topic I am a 28 year old born and raised
in Brooklyn that may not mean what it
used to but I know you're familiar with
what this detail implies imagine boys in
the hood but dialed down to about four
out of ten that's roughly what I grew up
in I had to learn how to avoid and
resolve conflicts like the one that led
to that disgusting and pointless loss of
life I want to begin by disagreeing with
the shooter decided to pull the trigger
yeah it was ridiculous he got pushed
down on the ground and the guy started
to walk away I personally could not pull
the trigger on a person like that though
I can imagine being in a position
leading up to that moment I don't want
to live in a world where this behavior
is condoned I'd also like to point out
that people where I'm from pull the
trigger for less
yeah I'm not advocating that one group
of people shouldn't shoot people and
other people should I'm just saying that
if you yell at somebody's girlfriend or
wife and the guy comes out and and
pushes you down to the ground that's not
a reason to use deadly force I mean
that's like that's like Wild West [ __ ]
anyways I think all of the adults made
bad choices that escalated to the
situation 100% agree with that first
using the differently labeled parking
when there are other available spots as
a dick move absolutely arguing in
defense of a move like that this is even
worse this is speculation but knowing
what I know about my own people in a
certain type of black woman if I as a
black man even politely said something
to that woman there is a very little
chance she respond politely
is what I don't know this is a [ __ ]
white dude or a black guy insert me in
that situation unarmed the men would
have knocked me down just like he did
the white to the white guy and [ __ ] me
up
no news coverage my own people would
have said I should have shut the [ __ ] up
yeah but he didn't [ __ ] him up he just
pushed him down and started to walk away
if he pushed him down and started
swinging on him I gotta be honest even
then even then I feel like to then pull
a gun this guy's throwing hands don't
you throw hands back it's just like the
untouchables so it brings a knife and
you bring a gun I mean Sicily I get a
[ __ ] gas station anyways this is why
I wouldn't have said [ __ ] I would have
minded my own business that's the school
up front but that is the pro and con of
where I come from and the world in
general I suppose you mind your own
business but then you add to a culture
where people disobey laws big or small
and no one is supposed to stand up for
decency though it is not hurting anyone
in that usual cent it's not cool to park
in those spots and it shouldn't be
tolerated yes but shouldn't that guy
have stepped to the guy you know rather
than waiting to the guy leaves and he
yells at the woman then he put he kind
of put him in that [ __ ] macho
position to stick up for his lady yeah
everybody was wrong in that you know but
I mean to then turn around a [ __ ]
shoot the guy I'm it's just it's as he's
you know starts to walk away it's just
[ __ ] insane anyways the black I
should not have initiated the physical
contact never wound what you can't kill
or the black version don't start [ __ ]
you can't finish it didn't even look
like he tried to dissolve the conflict
in another way also you never know what
a stranger is carrying legal weaponry or
otherwise yeah that's true in New York
everything is illegal but that doesn't
stop anyone the black guy was about to
stop that white man out do you think
that because I thought he pushed him
down and then walked away I recognized
that body language anywhere he only
backed up after seeing the gun at which
point the entire situation
should have been over that's another
thing he could have waived the gun at
him I'm not saying that the lady driving
the car or that guy did anything right
but to just [ __ ] shoot the guy it's
not something who continues to charge
when they see a gun a detail I'd like to
point out is that the black guy did not
put his hands up when the white man
pulled on him this is because we black
men have to look badass to matter this
sir I don't [ __ ] know about this [ __ ]
I don't know but I don't know who
[ __ ] wrote this you see this is
because we black might have to look
badass no matter the circumstances
however my hands would Bend so high in
the air I could have tickled God's feet
the white guy is supposedly known for
[ __ ] with people over disabled
parking spots he also supposedly
mentally unstable if those are facts he
shouldn't have been on the street or
allowed to carry a [ __ ] gun yeah well
that's another thing too they actually
do a bit about this how they've shut
down the nut houses when I was a kid if
you were [ __ ] crazy they put you in
the nuthouse and you combine the fact
that nut houses they just have those
people walking down the street now and
people who are into guns don't want to
wait more than 15 minutes to get one
you're gonna have a [ __ ] problem
anyways none of this [ __ ] should have
happened I'm tired of seeing my people
especially men died over dumb [ __ ] and
it only becomes news if there is a white
person involved also men have to rise
above getting into goofy arguments on
behalf of women especially when they're
wrong she's likely not going to get hurt
but you you are as a dude yeah that is
true not sure if you can feel I'm coming
from but I want to make my fellow black
men to be smarter and safer kids need
their father's best a fan for Brooklyn
PS met you once at the Beacon Theater
show we'll see you at MSG you are
awesome well thank you very much I agree
with everything that you said there
although I don't think it looked like he
was gonna stomp him out as you said I
also think that all you just take out a
gun if you do had a gun everybody
[ __ ] runs I don't know why that guy
didn't [ __ ] run maybe it just stunned
although I remember being at a
meet-and-greet one of the last ones I
did and this guy [ __ ] went to take a
picture of his girlfriend and wife
wanted a picture with me and he went to
reach in to pull out his camera in a
[ __ ] loaded 9-millimeter fell on the
floor
and this is how I reacted I went whoa
and pointed at it then he picked it up
and ran out of it cuz we were in a
casino and it was on Native American
land and you're not allowed turned out
he was an off-duty cop you know they
kind of [ __ ] handle it but I'm ever
saying to the security guys that Jesus
Christ I go you [ __ ] see that he goes
what happened I go up [ __ ] guy just I
had a loaded 9-millimeter just fell on
the ground and the security guy goes i
lucky I didn't see that I was like an
omen you know but um that's where my my
cul-de-sac suburban upbringing came into
effect where that was my first
experience with that so I was stunned
but now I played that over my head a
zillion times over that ever happens
again kick the [ __ ] got well if it's
AG lucky and she can kick anything else
it might go off I tackle the guy run
anything other than be like your guns
right there sir all right
out of everything you said I really
truly believe that hole the reason why I
don't [ __ ] with people aside from the
fact that I'm half a century old and you
know never really took any martial arts
I you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
running into you have no [ __ ] idea
the training the weaponry the level of
psycho the kind of day they're having if
a loved one just passed away you have no
idea what's going on in somebody's
[ __ ] life and you are rolling the
[ __ ] dice with your life when you
make a move like that and which I alone
I understand but I think it is [ __ ]
insane that there's a state out there
that allows citizens like the [ __ ]
Wild West to solve their problems like
that you know
that you can just shoot an unarmed guy
that pushed you down on the ground it's
just [ __ ] it's just it's such some
[ __ ] out of like Wyatt Earp you know and
I mean all you gun guys are gonna flip
out okay this is like just just picture
how the imagine the average [ __ ]
person drives just watch the average
person go through a [ __ ] security
line at the airport the amount of
awareness the amount of empathy the
mouth about mouth breathe and [ __ ]
morons and the fact that any of them can
go out and get a [ __ ] gun and then
stand their ground using that [ __ ] 20
year old laptop between their ears that
is their [ __ ] brain I mean that is
some crazy crazy level of [ __ ] second
degree I mean second Second Amendment
[ __ ] freedom that usually leads to
[ __ ] second degree murder as far as
Einstein I am I am NOT an anti-gun guy
but I am also like you know I just don't
want people you know walking around like
they're in [ __ ] Westworld
alright girlfriend's parents no in
defense of Florida you don't see that
every day though you know you do not see
that every day so I don't know if they'd
be there sorry there's always arguments
on both sides girlfriend's parents no
hey Bill I'm 17 going into my senior
year of high school and I'm dating this
amazing girl who's about to be a junior
she's half black half Filipino Filipino
as I said Filipino Filipino I'm a few
days darker I'm a few shades days few
shades darker than a piece of printer
paper anyways hey welcome to the club
buddy anyways we've been dating for
about a month now and obviously we've
hooked up a couple of times and neither
one of our parents even knew
a couple days ago her parents asked her
if I was a virgin and for some god
unknown reason she told them that I had
been with a couple of other girls during
highschool that wasn't a big deal until
today when they started asking if her
and I had ever had sex apparently she
didn't get the female line gene and told
them everything well I mean sounds like
she has a really open relationship with
her parents I don't know what to do I'm
sure is it dad you can imagine what you
would do to a guy in my position and her
dad is 6 foot 4 260 pound black dude I'm
about 6 foot 2 160 on a good day so I'm
not stacking up well against that I'm
not looking forward to going back over
to our house and talking to her parents
or meeting her older brother that's
coming to town on Monday any advice from
you and Nia and how to not get killed
would be great yeah dude I I would be a
[ __ ] man about it and I would go over
there and just be honest just say what
you're done and how you feel about her
daughter and then what what do they mean
what are you gonna do I don't I don't
know I don't know how old of you is is
how old is your 17 okay see I don't know
what the [ __ ] how old is your
girlfriend dude don't listen to me I
don't know what the [ __ ] to do I don't
know what to do now you got me all
[ __ ] nervous I would have to think
that if she [ __ ] if he asked her they
asked her what she's doing and she was
just honest about it they seem a little
[ __ ] open-minded like if I don't know
this is crazy thing to say but if she
knew that he was gonna flip out and try
to [ __ ] kill you why would she say
something she could be scared of him I
don't know dude you got yourself into a
little bit of a quagmire I have no idea
I have no idea - I would go over there
and when he says what's up little man
I'd be like hey um you know I guess
that's when as a man you get into your
hypocritical years when you meet another
guy who is doing or trying to do exactly
what the [ __ ] you were doing when you
were 17 it doesn't sound like you're
running around trying to dog other
chicks and do all of this type of [ __ ] I
don't [ __ ] know you know what I don't
know I don't [ __ ] know and now I'm
thinking what's gonna happen when Mike
gets that [ __ ] age I have no idea I
have no idea all I know is that I'm
hoping she's at least gonna be a brown
belt in jujitsu you know which I
actually I I you know I think every
woman should learn that [ __ ] you know
it's perfect it's in close and if a
guy's you know doing something you don't
want them to do it's so [ __ ] easy
armbar get him in a triangle but then
what the [ __ ] you know choke him out and
then just call the cops there he is
it's perfect you know I don't [ __ ]
know anyways
Jesus Christ I get me thinking all this
crazy [ __ ] all I can say it's good luck
to you sir and uh you've got some
decisions to make I mean wouldn't you
want to keep seeing this woman I mean
what are you gonna do I feel like you
kind of got to go over there so the guy
respects you then what's he gonna do six
foot four he's gonna beat the [ __ ] out
of a 17 year old wait a minute you're
not in Florida are you if you're in
Florida don't go over there because he
might stand his ground all right I got
to go you guys
thank you so much you're awesome for
writing in all you women who wrote in
all you ladies are wrote in I really
appreciate that because I wanted to give
that woman some good advice and we
needed to hear it from the ladies I'm
gonna be in Las Vegas this weekend with
Joe I'm flying out the [ __ ]
helicopter and then the day after I'm
getting up before I go home I'm flying
over to Utah to fly through something
like [ __ ] canyons and all this [ __ ]
then I'm coming back it's gonna be
[ __ ] incredible and I'm picking up
eight hours on the stick creeping
towards 200 that'll get me up to about a
buck 85 and I'm very very excited and
I've decided that I want to get my
instrument rating as a pilot cuz every
pilot I talked to it's like that is a
[ __ ] game changer I just have to
carve out some time where I can do it
and I figure if Tom Cruise can figure
out how to point it at the ground and do
[ __ ] 360 says he's doing it god damn
it I can get my instrument rating all
right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves I'll
check in on you on Thursday